y vamos a orar con la información
económica para ello me acompaña
daniela blandón bienvenida comenzamos en
américa latina porque todos los países
perdieron competitividad durante la
pandemia o la marina buenas noches
primero recordemos que es competitividad
pues esto tiene que ver con qué tan
atractivas son las condiciones de
determinado país para la inversión
basados en varios aspectos como por
ejemplo el rendimiento económico la
eficiencia gubernamental la eficiencia
empresarial y la infraestructura en el
caso de américa latina la irrupción de
la pandemia hizo que todos los países
cayeran en 2020 en el ranking mundial
que hace cada año el instituto para el
desarrollo gerencial de suiza en la
clasificación que lideran suiza suecia y
dinamarca ninguno de los siete países
latinoamericanos analizados está por
encima del puesto 44 chile y perú fueron
los que más bajaron peldaños méxico
colombia y brasil descendieron al menos
un puesto y argentina y venezuela
quedaron en el fondo de la tabla
y vamos ahora el salvador porque el
banco mundial no va a ayudar al país a
implementar el bitcoin pues hay que
recordar que en medio de una lluvia de
críticas del gobierno de nadie buque le
impulsó y logró sacar adelante un
proyecto para que la cripto moneda más
transada del mundo sea usada como moneda
de curso legal algo que hasta el momento
no ha hecho ningún país justamente por
el riesgo que esto representa esto haría
que desde salarios hasta transacciones
comerciales se pueden realizar con
bitcoin pero el país tiene menos de tres
meses para implementarlo y lo primero
que hizo fue pedir ayuda técnica al
banco mundial para elaborar un
reglamento la entidad multilateral
rechazó la petición argumentando que hay
deficiencias medioambientales y de
transparencia y es que marín a la ley ha
sido muy criticada por el riesgo de que
el país se vuelva un paraíso fiscal y
porque el uso de cripto monedas demanda
grandes demanda grandes cantidades de
energía eléctrica
y lo hablábamos un poquito durante las
noticias pero la comunidad internacional
comprometió ayudas a los países que
reciban lo que acojan a migrantes
venezolanos
bueno este jueves como lo decíamos se
llevó a cabo en toronto canadá la
conferencia internacional de donantes en
solidaridad con los refugiados
inmigrantes venezolanos los países
participantes acordaron más de 1500
millones de dólares en ayudas para los
cerca de 57 millones de personas que
están en esta condición de ese total 600
millones son préstamos moody's con
multilaterales el resto son donaciones
que vienen principalmente lo vemos en el
gráfico de eeuu canadá y españa uno de
los compromisos a los que se llegó es
que colombia y otras naciones como perú
ecuador república dominicana de eeuu
concedan un estatus de protección
temporal a gran parte de esta población
y salimos la médica latina nos vamos
hasta asia en hong kong se sortean hasta
lingotes de oro para vacunarse contra el
coi 19 bueno algo bien interesante
marina yo lo haría yo participaría pues
vive muchos escépticos de en este
territorio semiautónomo
no tenían planes inmediatos para recibir
vacunas pero más de uno cambio de
opinión cuando se supo que varias
empresas privadas alentadas por el
gobierno iban a dar esta clase de
incentivos como sucede también en eeuu
entre ellos está el sorteo de un lujoso
apartamento evaluado en 1,4 millones de
dólares en este que es uno de los
mercados inmobiliarios más costosos del
mundo el día que se anunció la rifa
marina se inscribieron unas 450.000
personas y el premio se entrega en
septiembre pero con certificado de
vacunación en mar también se han lanzado
sorteos de lingotes de oro como lo
decíamos e incluso del nuevo vehículo
tesla para convencer a la mayor cantidad
posible de los 7,5 millones de
habitantes de los cuales sólo el 16 por
ciento ha sido completamente vacuna otra
preocupación tiene que ver con que hay
cientos de miles de dosis de vacunas no
utilizadas pzifer bayón tec que se van a
vencer en agosto y que se pueden perder
bueno pues por si la pandemia no es
suficiente para vacunarse un tesla no
estaría mal vamos con los indicadores
del día
bueno la bolsa de nueva york que cerró
mis mixta todavía influenciado por las
perspectivas económicas lanzadas por la
reserva federal
las acciones europeas del cerraron
ligeramente a la baja también como
reacción a la fed que dijo que puede
endurecer su política monetaria antes de
lo previsto y un cierre negativo para
las bolsas de américa latina sao paulo
por ejemplo encadena su tercera caída
consecutiva y cuentan los cuales la
cifra del día el 39% que se desplomaron
en wall street en las acciones de la
alemana curva que después de conocerse
que tiene una eficacia de apenas el 47
por ciento para prevenir el comicios y
nueve gracias daniela gracias a ustedes
hay más información en nuestra página
web